alors j'ai presque envie de dire que
c'est deux jours que nous avons passé
ensemble
d'abord Marc notre rentrée pas
parlementaire bien sûr
Marc aussi
des souvenirs d'une année passée à vos
côtés
souvent avec des collègues que j'attends
12 ans
pour des réunions informelles et
formelles sur la marche un petit peu du
travail législatif
et je voulais d'abord dire que
c'était encore comment je sais pas je
fais c'est formellement je me dis pas je
pourrais choqué personne le
beaucoup d'admiration sur l'engagement
que tu as pour
un bâtillon en Première ministre ça n'a
pas été une année facile même si
beaucoup de textes ont été adoptés
ça a été une année intense où l'ensemble
des collègues ont été là présents en
soutien
certes force de proposition
parfois peut-être
pour les gratter comme on dit mais
toujours en responsabilité en solidarité
et la volonté de bien faire
et c'est deux journées on a commencé
lundi matin par
trois ateliers un atelier sur
l'agriculture avec Marc feno qui a
quelque chose
bien accès avec ce projet de loi et qui
matérialise le lien entre les
territoires qui me semblent
excessivement important ensuite on a eu
un échange
bien évidemment avec
Olivier Deschamps sur la loi plein
d'emploi et avec un focus important sur
l'insertion et les travaux ont été très
intéressants et nos conclusions étaient
très intéressantes et enfin on a une
discussion avec le nouveau ministre du
Budget Thomas casdan que je connaissais
déjà puisqu'il siégé avec nous pour
certains membres la Commission des
finances à la commission des finances et
on a fait certaines propositions
en responsabilité
voulant marquez une volonté d'échanges
et de
et de construction
sans être créatif au plaisir d'être
créatif mais essayez de réfléchir de
compter certains sujets en un abordera
peut-être que faisa
dans le débat l'après-midi on a eu une
une table ronde intéressante sur
l'immigration alors il y a des tribus
des autres qui sont qui sont faites et
je pense que ce
cet après-midi d'hier je sais pas ce
qu'on pense mes collègues a bien permis
de cranter le débat on avait à la fois
Gérald darmadame elle avait également
des représentants ONG
également le sénateur bonne Carrère qui
a des lentes grande expérience sur ces
sujets et c'était débat qui nous a
permis de nous densifier dans nos
pensées essayer d'accompagner un texte
qui n'est pas fini et c'est justement
l'enjeu parlementaire le travail
parlementaire que nous devons mener on
doit assumer notre responsabilité est-ce
que ces binaire article 3 article 3 je
crois que le débat n'est pas là c'est
comment on avance et comment on
construit pour aboutir un texte qui soit
adopté de manière apaisée à l'Assemblée
à l'Assemblée nationale ensuite
nous avons
évoqué ce matin les territoires avec
Christophe
avec un débat particulièrement
intéressant que le président
donc du département des départements
avec une longue expérience et du local
ça se sent moi j'ai écouté dans mon
propos véritable expérience là aussi
nous sommes des nous sommes des acteurs
de terrain avec nous même la plupart
d'entre nous l'ont d'expérience des
vidéos locales et ça a été
particulièrement
ça nous a permis de débattre évidemment
hier soir nous avons un débat sur la
guerre du monde avec
Jean-Louis
Vollandes avec son collègue président de
la commission du sida
postovaquie qui nous a beaucoup ouvert
l'esprit
et qui a
apporté dans le débat à la fois
l'angoisse et puis qui mettait les
curseurs
un certain niveau voilà il faut prôner
aussi une vision mondiale des enjeux de
notre de notre planète voilà donc
deux jours de travail de jour qui montre
le service de du groupe l'envie de bien
faire
un esprit de cohésion le sérieux de nos
de nos propositions
pour nous la façon de faire la politique
qui me semble la plus appropriée
actuellement nous devons être
responsable de devant être exemplaire et
puis ce lieu qui symbolique Nicolas
turquois qui a beaucoup d'humour disait
que nous étions dans la salle des non
pas des quatre colonnes mais dans la
salle des six colonnes voilà et c'est
vrai donc ça va nous préparer pour la
rentrée parlementaire qui va être
intense mais on sera chère Elisabeth à
vos côtés
en solidarité en responsabilité et avec
quelques
idées sur plein de sujets vous savez
qu'on est créatif et on le restera mais
en responsabilité je remercie
encore
[Applaudissements]